okay good morning so today we do the
simic revolution okay and um as I
mentioned in previous classes it was
really Dante who helped give give birth
to the idea of mity and he really
launched three major movements which
include the Renaissance the pro
reformation and the S Revolution okay we
will not have mity without um
Dante okay
all right so let's see how the three
connect together okay we're going to
review um the previous two classes to
connect to today's class on the S
Revolution so the Renaissance what it
was was it was a celebration of what
makes us human before we were focus on
the Divine on the idea of God now we
want to tell the story of what it means
to be human okay that's a Renaissance
prism believes that we have direct
access to God um the Catholic religion
um the pope is the Divine representative
and the clergy is the um spokesperson
for um for God but pris prism believes
that we have direct access to God we
should be able to speak with God
directly Through the
Bible um the C Revolution it's really
about how can we know God okay that's
the idea of the retion ution so let's
review why we have these ideas and it
has to do with Dante so remember last we
discuss the dialogue between beatric and
uh Dante let's review it really quickly
so beatress is saying I just said that
God is perfect whatever God touches
whatever God creates is perfect so if
that's the case why is it that there is
Decay destruction and death in this
world what are the forces that give rise
to this Decay and then she explains okay
whatever God creates is perfect so
angels are perfect they're Immortal
they're Eternal but the elements that
are in this world they are not created
by God what is created by God are the
Divine laws that underly the universe
God create the atoms God create create
the laws that allow these atoms to enact
with each other okay so the Rays and
motion of the Holy lights draw forth the
soul of every animal and plant from
matter able to take form so it's these
Divine laws to create the animals and
the plants um but these Divine laws also
necess necessitate that they die in
order for new forms to come into being
okay so this is the idea of evolution
um we humans are special why because we
are both divinely created and created by
the laws of the universe we have a dual
nature and the main advantage of this
dual nature is it gives us a capacity to
imagine remember remember the issue with
God is that God is perfect if you're
perfect if you're Eternal if you're IM
mutable you lack an imagination because
there are no boundaries to you but if
you're human you're forced of an
imagination because you'll make mistakes
you will fail there are things that you
do not know the imagination gives you
the capacity to um know this world and
to perfect this world okay so that's
what it means to be fundamentally human
Okay so let's recap okay these are the
three main messages that Dante is
relaying to us through his poetry first
of all God is within us how do we know
because we are capable of loving others
God is the light of Love within us the
more we love someone the more this light
grows in us okay so we we must focus on
loving someone who is dear to us second
idea is we have the imagination and thus
responsibility to discover the universal
laws underlying reality God created the
laws of the universe God created us in
order to know these laws okay that's
very fundamental Al to the idea of
science the last idea is we can Master
these laws to better our reality okay so
this these are the three hidden messages
of Divine Comedy that will influence
development of Science in the Western
World okay so I want to talk briefly
about science that has been
traditionally been practiced in ancient
societies okay um so in ancient
societies the the major ancient
civilizations are China Egypt and India
and you will see a lot of
similarities uh among these three civil
civilizations on how they practice the
idea of science okay it's very intuitive
it's very
imaginative um it it will make sense to
you okay so um the first science that
they focus a lot on is the idea of
secret geometry I'm not I'm not sure if
you've heard of this okay but the idea
of secret geometry is that the
underlying fundamental structure
of the universe of reality are geometric
shapes okay and from these geometric
shapes you can give rise to every
possible reality all right so um um this
is called the Egg of life and from the
Egg of life if you just keep on
expanding it you will get all of reality
okay um these actually 3D 4D shapes I
can't illustrate them but if you're but
if you're curious go online these are
beautiful um um
ideas okay um so there are two possible
ways to understand sacred geometry the
first possible way is to understand
understand as solids okay so the
Egyptians understood them as solids and
Plato understood them as solids remember
Plato um a lot of his philosophy is
derived from the Egyptians and the idea
of sacred geometry it's very apparent in
Plato's writings and he got this from
the Egyptians so basically the idea is
that if you train yourself on how to
understand s geometry and how to
manipulate secr geometry in your head
you can access God okay so the first
idea is to understand it as solid but
there's another way you can understand C
geometry and it's as vibrations as
energy as a force okay and this is the
way that the Chinese understand sa right
as Chi as life force also as well as the
Hindus and so imagine a monk who's
breathing okay who's meditating what is
he what is he doing he's breathing and
he's meditating and he's focusing his
energies in order to achieve the sacred
geometry within him the the monk will
often say things like
om
om om okay he's causing vibrations that
try to mimic the sacred
geometry why is he doing this because
the belief at this time is that if there
is a God okay if there are a if there's
a creat God the question is how
does it think right it's not going to
think with words the way we do it's
going to think using mathematics with
SEC geometry and by
thinking he is going to create the
underlying
universe and how does he do that he does
it by breathing breathing in ating SEC
geometry and then breathing out
breathing back in okay inhaling exhaling
and this will give rise to the universe
so if you're a monk or a priest you
practice meditation in order to try to
mimic the act of creation and if you are
able to succeed then what will happen is
you harmonize your self with the
vibrations of the universe and therefore
you're able to access Divine energy okay
so that that's the idea of sacred
geometry and again it's a very
complicated um idea but that's a general
gist um any
questions okay and again this this make
intuitive sense okay this should make
intuitive sense to you all right the
second Big Field that the Egyptians are
Chinese and the indan Indians were um
really compa really passionate about is
astronomy and astrology okay so the
Egyptians basically created astrology
and the idea is that you're trying to
link the movement of the Stars the
cosmos with events in the world okay so
by understanding the moveing the Stars
you're able to divide or predict the
future of humanity okay every major um
King had an astrologist in order to
Divine the future through the practice
of astronomy and astrology all right and
the last thing is alchemy what is
alchemy Alchemy is basically chemistry
and sorcery combine together um this is
a polytheistic world and the idea is
that because it's a polytheistic world
it's a cha chaotic world and somehow if
you are clever enough you're able to
hack this world okay think think of it
as hacking that there are secrets to
this world
and you are able to take elements in
this world combined together in create
something called the philosopher stone
the philosopher stone is the power of
God in order to give you the elixir of
immortality in order to live forever as
well as to manipulate the environment so
basically turn lead into gold and again
this was an extremely popular practice
um in ancient societies okay so these
are three major
Sciences in uh the Primitive societies
China Egypt and India and they um Pro
they ProMag outwards and influence other
societies we still have them today okay
there are still people who practice
Alchemy um Sac geometry and um astrology
today okay um any questions about this
before I move
on okay so this is primitive primitive
science so the question then is what's
the difference okay so let's focus on
the three major differences between um
premodern science and modern science
okay the first major difference is it
focuses focus focus on the spiritual
World on the outer worldly all right and
the point of science was to create
Harmony between our world and the
spiritual World okay because if you
harmonize these two worlds you can have
a more prosperous more peaceful
future um today we are only focused on
the Material World the world that we can
see and know in order to create progress
okay we've abandoned the spiritual world
and we focus on this material world in
order to manipulate it in order to
promote technological progress and quite
honestly we have been extremely
successful at that in fact I will argue
we've been too successful at that okay
so that's the first major difference
between premodern and modern science
second major difference is that
premodern science relies entirely on
intuition and Imagination okay you don't
do experiments you don't um have
conferences you don't debate you just
meditate you just
dream okay and you often fall into
transes in order to communicate with the
spiritual World um in this world they
use a lot of Hello um um
hellenics okay they um a lot of
psychedelics okay including magic
mushroom
a drink called Som which is very um
important in the Hindu religion um as as
as well as the Zoras religion it's
basically a psychedelic okay um today we
don't rely on intuition imagination we
think this is um superstitious we rely
mainly on something called the Sonic
method okay and in in in um later on I
will discuss the Sonic method more in
detail right now last thing is in
premodern science people are relying on
divine inspiration in order to discover
the truth the big question is what is
truth today we care about the question
how do we know truth okay it's really
the idea of in the intialization of
Doubt our M our main priority is to
question and doubt the truth and what
and what and what will happen is because
of this emphasis change we've changed
from what is truth to how do we know
truth it will launch a
revolution in Tech technological
progress all
right all right so underline theic
Revolution are three major theological
assumptions without these theological
assumptions the S Revolution would not
be possible okay so the first and most
important idea is the idea of monotheism
there is one
God okay and again uh the very idea of
monotheism is also revolutionary in
human
thought second idea is that God designed
and will the universe into being so
there is an intelligent design to the
universe and it's up to us to discover
this
design God endowed us with the capacity
to discover his design and will okay so
these are the three major theological
assumptions underlying the C Revolution
that is why these that is why the
revolution happened in Western Europe
and not say in China or the Islamic
world or India okay because you need at
these three theological
assumptions okay so what do these
assumptions bring us okay so let's look
at at Poly polytheism again throughout
most of human
history uh most societies have been
thought polytheistic what is the
difference between a polytheistic
worldview of Science and a monotheistic
worldview of science okay so I I I I I
need you to memorize this chart okay the
first major difference is in a PO
polytheistic system there's there's
really no design there's really no
progress It's just chaos and struggle
but in a monistic worldview there is an
underlying truth to the universe okay
that's the first difference second major
difference is the idea of Randomness
things happen for no particular reason
if you um win the lottery that's great
okay but if you lose all your wealth
that's just random okay there's it's
just fate it's just Destiny there's no
purpose or no design to your fate but in
the monistic world there's the idea of
Good and Evil evil things happen to you
that benefit you if you're doing good
but if you're doing evil then bad things
will happen to you okay so there's a
very um there's a deep sense that God is
in our lives orchestrating events the
last major difference is that between
fate and progress okay if there's truth
in this world if there's goodness in
this world then we have a responsibility
to to progress by doing good and by
discovering this truth okay that's why U
I keep on emphasizing this but mon
monotheism is really an intellectual
revolution first and
foremost okay so um the S reolution
happens and what drives it okay there
are three major forces that drive the S
Revolution the first is the idea of the
pro of reformation and the C re
Reformation so the proest have come and
their challenging authority of the
church and the church responds by um
what something called The Counter
Reformation there is this belief or
there's this
Prejudice um that the church is
anti-science the church the Catholic
church is not anti science in fact the
both the Protestants and the Catholic
Church are trying to use science in
order to promote their legitimacy and
Authority okay so the Protestants are
heavily uh devoted to science because
because they want to un understand the
will and mind of God the Catholics
themselves are also promoting science um
the Catholics will create a new society
called the Jesuits who are renowned for
um for for being great scientists in
fact a lot of universities in this world
were founded by
Jesuits um a lot of Jesuits came to
China and they promoted knowledge and
Science in China and this has been true
for many centuries Okay so both the
Catholic church and the Protestant
movement they are in a struggle to use
science in order to promote their own
authority and legitimacy okay that's the
first Major Force driving the
revolution second is war during this
time Europe is in constant state of War
it's fighting amongst themselves um
between the Catholics and the
Protestants um it's also fighting with
the Muslims okay the Ottoman Empire
which is at this point um the strongest
Empire
in um in the world all right and last
idea that's driving science is the Age
of Exploration and Conquest as Europe is
trying to expand outwards if they're
going to North America they're going to
South America they need better
navigation tools they need compasses
they need um um astrolabs okay they they
so science solves all three problems
okay okay so
again the Sim Revolution the best way to
remember Simon Revolution is it's a
fundamental change from asking what is
truth to how do we know truth okay how
can we know
truth
and believe it or not but no one really
bothered to ask this question before how
can we know truth okay um and because
science is asking this question how do
we know no truth what it's really doing
is it's separating itself from
religion and putting itself above
religion okay because religion purports
to be the truth right and what science
is saying is like how do you know if you
if you're
right well we know if you're right
because we have methods to test you okay
so science is putting itself above
religion and as you can imagine this
will create conflicts um within the
Catholic Church very very soon um mainly
in the trial of Galileo
okay
so because science asks this question
how do we know truth what it does is it
creates the cic method okay um and the
cic method is composed of three
main um elements the first is you ask
questions and you propose hypothesis so
there are no questions now that are out
of bounds and you have to think of
solutions and ideas to solve these
questions okay so that's the first step
second step is there are these processes
and protocols for testing hypothesis
experimentation basically right so o
only if you can experiment only if you
can only if your hypothesis matches
experimental results can it be true the
last thing is it creates a system of
doubt and criticism in order to test all
experimental results and today we call
them um academic societies and per
review journals okay so if you're a
scientist working today at a
university um whatever results you have
you have you must first publish and then
you have to present your Journal results
um to a conference of peers who will
criticize you and they will look for
Flaws in your argument and this is an
extremely effective system on how to
know what is true and again because of
the system it's allowed for a remarkable
explosion of wealth and technology and
progress in the world
today and this is the chart that shows
us okay so um for most of human history
progress uh meaning productivity has
been flat and then starting around the
year 1700 it starts to exponentially
rise
okay and this has meant that we are now
able to feed more and more people so um
before 1700 you really couldn't get
above a few hundred million people and
now we are at n we are projected to
reach n billion people um and you can
ask is this a good thing and I will
argue it's not a good thing but it shows
us the remarkable power of science
okay all right so now the question then
is what caused theic method to
arise and it really has to do with a
major debate uh among
scientists it was it was the duocentric
versus the hoc Centric debate Okay now
what's interesting is that um if you
look at the Egyptians they knew that um
the sun was the center of the universe
that's why their God was a Sun God Ra
okay um but by the time you had the you
hit the Greeks there was now this diers
between those who believe that the uh
Universe revolved around the Sun and
those who believed it revolved around
the
earth um in about 150 a Greek scientist
named tmy working in Egypt he developed
the first
comprehensive uh cosmological system and
this cosm cosmological system which he
wrote um in a book called The
amus he made certain um arguments okay
the first first argument is that the
Earth stands still okay the Earth does
not move it doesn't revolve okay second
is that all other celestial bodies
including the moon including the Stars
the planets revolve around the Earth in
a circular
motion okay why because in the heavens
it is assumed that EV is perfect okay so
for example um on planet Earth we breath
something called a right we we ear
oxygen is what gives us life but up
there in the space ear becomes ether
ether is the ear that the gods breathe
ether is what allows the world the
Heavens to be perfect okay and
so and this is the Arabic um addition of
the alagas and as you can see there you
can't read this but there's a lot of
mathematical detail in uh the book and
because Tommy's perspective aligned with
theology the
Bible um it was accepted it was accepted
Truth for over a thousand years okay um
there golden age relied heavily on to's
understanding of the
cosmos but the first person to suggest
that this model is wrong is uh cerus
okay who is a Polish polymath he did
many things he did astrology he also did
astronomy okay and and and when he died
in 1543 he proposed the hiloc Centric
model now what's really important for us
to remember is that Copernicus was a
devote Catholic and many of his friends
were um major figures within the
Catholic church and guess what they were
extremely supportive of his theory in
fact they want they wanted him to
publish his
theory okay why because at this point
there is no conflict between science and
religion so the saying back then is it
is the job of the church the Catholic
Church to tell you how to go to heaven
not how the heavens go okay so the
Catholic Church didn't really care
one way they didn't care about the
theocentric model or theocentric model
they didn't care at all so Copernicus
was heavily supported the problem with
Copernicus is that the mathematics
didn't really make sense okay so if I
put two books in front of you uh kernus
book called um on the Revolutions of the
celestial spheres or tomy's book well
most scientists would tell you that
Tommy's book is better okay there's more
math it's it's more well argue and the
reason why is um Copernicus his idea is
new and so there was not that much time
he didn't have that much time to refine
it people didn't really have time to
work on it whereas Tom me people
thousands of people have been working it
over the centuries okay so the GE
Centric model it is much more refined
much more accepted at this point than
the hoc Centric
model um we there this this man his name
is Tao bra and he is um a a Danish um
pooth as well he comes from a very Noble
family and he spent a lot of his
time doing
observations okay he um collected a lot
of data he observed how the planets
evolve and his conclusion is
that um the decentric and the hoc
Centric model are both correct and this
and this and this proposal was that
Earth was the center of the world but
the planets revolved around the Sun Okay
so Sun revolved around the earth and
every other system revolved around the
Sun okay so that's what he that's what
he derived from his um data now he he
had a prodig named johans Kepler he's a
German and he looked at the data and he
and he discovered that the data actually
uh makes the HELOC Centric model um
actually supports the hric model more
than the geocentric model and but
because he is not a member of the
Catholic Church he's a Lutheran okay um
the Catholic Church couldn't really do
do anything about him right and what's
remarkable about capler is that just
from this data he was able to make
certain predictions about the stars that
we've confirmed over time uh the first
is that the
sun uh so every revolves around the Sun
his problem though is that he didn't put
the Sun at the center of the universe he
put something else at the center of the
universe the sun revolved around that
and the Earth revolved around the Sun
second uh Major law of plan motion is
that the orbit is actually not circular
it's elliptical okay that's what the
data was telling him all right and this
goes against theology because remember
in theology the heavens are perfect
right that because that's where God
lives but um um cap is saying nope the
universe sorry the orbit is
elliptical and then what he what else he
did that was revolutionary is that he he
de he discovered that there was a
correlation between this orbit and the
mass of the planet okay and this will
give rise to Newton but Kepler um made
all these revolutionary discoveries um
now comes Galileo and Galileo um he
lives in Florence at this time um and so
he's under the purview of the Catholic
Church
so um he comes from a pretty normal
background he when he grew up he wanted
to be a monk but his dad um wanted him
wanted him become a doctor instead and
then he they made it compromised and he
said I'll go study mathematics but his
dad was insistent that he go study
medicine eventually um G Galileo managed
to uh go do do what he wanted and just
do science okay um at this point they
invented a telescope and this was not a
great telescope so so the telescope
could give you three times the
magnification of of the human eye okay
but it's not that great but with this
telescope this new invention Galileo did
amazing things first thing he did was he
discovered that the Jupiter had moons
and this was revolutionary because it
was assumed that everything revolved
around a planet um Earth but now he
showed that moons revolved around
Jupiter he also recognized that um from
the earth you're able to
see um Venus spin around us and that
also was revolutionary because it was
assumed
that um Earth Stood Still and all the
planets Stood Still okay so he wrote
this book and it was a sensation he
became like the court scientist to the
medi family and the Catholic Church
thought this book was great okay but the
thing about Galileo which is very
important is that he was a very arrogant
man and because he was Pro promoting the
hoc Centric model he was coming into
conflict with a lot of academics that
were extremely wellestablished who made
their living of the geocentric model
okay so they having these arguments and
um
Galileo's um arguments were very limited
remember this is a new idea it's not
really supported by mathematics it's not
really supported by a lot of data okay
so Galileo's entire logic was I speak to
God I know the truth and you're all
idiots okay that was basically how he
spoke to his enemies and as you can
imagine he had more and more enemies and
as you can also Imagine his enemies were
devising ways to get at Galileo one
thing that Galileo was saying privately
that he should not have been saying is
that people were saying to him listen
this htic model it's fine but it goes
against scripture okay let's look at
scripture scripture says that um the
Earth it's firm and immovable okay
that's what the Bible says also if you
look if you look at Genesis it's clear
that God created the Earth first and
then he created the heavens the sun and
the moon and the stars so
logically everything should revolve
around Earth so h g how do you explain
this conflict between your theory of uh
the hoc Centric model and scripture and
Gallo's response
was it's my job to interpret scpt
scripture and this as you remember from
uh last week it's
heresy okay if you disagree with the
church that's not heresy that could just
be ignorance okay but if you believe
that you are above the church if you
refuse to accept the authority of the
church if you believe that I interpret
the the Bible better than the church
church that is heresy okay so G was
called before the Inquisition he was
explained as to explain himself and
Gallo was pretty confident you know he
had to support the med medis he he was a
very famous author he was extremely
intelligent he thought that God loved
him okay so as can imagine it was
complete
disaster it was a disastrous meeting the
the Inquisition told him to shut up okay
you you can write anything you want
privately but do not promote your views
anymore and because if if you were
guilty of heresy you could be burnt at
the stake G had no choice but to follow
this order okay that is
until um 1632 what happened 1632 well
the old Pope died and the new Pope Urban
the E came into Power who is urban the E
well he was a very good friend of
galileos and urban the e was a huge
admirer of G of alos okay so Galo felt
he now had permission to get back at his
enemies so he wrote a book called
dialogue concerning the Two Chief World
system and it was it it was basically
like almost like a platonic dialogue
okay where he presented his argument
again for the hiloc Centric model not
not only that but he made fun of his
enemies so it's a dialogue um and the
chief enemy of Galileo his name was
simplicius okay simplicius not
only that but he put into the mouth of
simplicit a lot of the
arguments from Pope Urban the E okay so
he was making fun of the Pope even
though they were very good friends so as
you can imagine the pope was really
pissed at first he banned this book and
what happens when you ban a book you
make it into a national bestseller okay
so everyone was reading this book so now
Urban age was really angry and so he
called for the Inquisition okay so Galo
was haed before the
Inquisition and G now had to explain
himself and G Leo was coming up with a
lot of like really silly excuses so so
he said is listen this book it's it's a
satire it's a thought experiment Corp I
know that the HELOC Centric model is
wrong and so I wrote this book
to um as in intellectual exercise to see
how wrong it could be and to see if it
could be right okay so so so he saying
saying things like this didn't work and
they uh basically put him um under
arrest okay at this point um G's friends
pleaded with the Pope and the pope said
fine I'm a generous person I will
commute his sentence to house arrest for
the rest of his life okay so that is a
story of Galo all right so you can make
the argument that it was Galileo's
personality that was just responsible
for the trial for his trial and downfall
he was it was his hubris it's a very
classic classic uh Greek tragedy but um
historically that's not what how we
remember this the story The reason why
is again remember there's a major
conflict between the pressant and the
Catholics so the pressant will use this
trial as propaganda against the church
and the pro will say you see how anti-
science the uh church is and G will will
we remember now as a father of modern
science because he put science above
religion and even though Galo um was
disgraced during his time eventually
what will happen is the florentines the
people Florence they will dig up his
grave and put uh his body beside
Michelangelo and Dante
all right that's how that's that's how
they much they revered the contribution
of
Galileo okay all right so um again even
though the theory of hoc Centric ISM it
is correct the mathematics didn't make
any sense at this time in history if you
had a team of scientists go and look at
the geocentric argument versus
theocentric argument they would say the
geocentric argument makes more s ofic
sense okay it was not until Newton when
the mathematics came into being that
allowed for the HELOC Centric model to
be widely accepted Newton as you know
he's the person who created calculus the
calculus you're learning in school guess
what he was responsible for the creation
of calculus now what's really
interesting for us to know about Newton
is Newton didn't really see himself as a
mathemat mathematician or scientist
these were s Hobbies what he really was
was a the Theologian okay so he spent
most of his time actually reading the
Bible because he was convinced that
withing the Bible were the secrets of
the universe specifically he wanted to
know when the world would end okay and
he and he spent his most of his life
doing these calculations and he told us
that the world will probably end I don't
know 2060 okay 2050 2060 around then so
he spent most of his time doing theology
this is important for us because
even at this time even as soci
Revolution it's gaining steam there is
no separation between religion and
science people understood Faith as a
very important Cornerstone of science
without faith how could you have the
energy and the inspiration to understand
the mind of God okay um Newton is also
famous for being an alchemist so he
spent most of his time also doing these
science experiments where you're trying
to combine different elements
unfortunately chemistry at this point
it's very primitive so he was taking
Mercury okay he was convinced that
mercury will lead to the phos stone and
he was eating it he was tasting it and
as a result he had a lot of mercury
poisoning problems he couldn't sleep he
had delusions his hair was falling out
um he had mercury poisoning okay but at
the same time he had the inspiration to
come up with the mathematics to prove
the h model is correct okay um the pr
the book he wrote is called the
principia um at this time Latin is the
um universal language of of scientists
right and also by the time also guys um
at this time they're not called
scientists they're called natural
philosophers all right science is
considered a part of
philosophy all right so in
1687 the this debate ended with the
publication of this book Newton used
mathematics to prove once and for all um
this the the helic model uh this is one
page from the principia as you can see
there are a lot of mathematics there are
a lot of diagrams
okay um in this book you also find his
laws of motions so Newton's great
Insight was that the probably the laws
of attraction gravity that govern this
world probably probably govern the
heavens as well okay so before it's
assumed that the heavens and the Earth
were separate and now he's saying that
no these are combined together and he
created um laws of planetary motion okay
he he figured out the mathematics that
um that told us relationship between the
the size of the planets and mass and how
they orbited okay now the problem though
he had a huge problem the problem is he
had the correlation he had the
mathematical correlation but he didn't
know why the correlation existed he
didn't have he couldn't solve the
causation problem okay there's just no
way that God would spend his time moving
the planets around he was much too busy
so there had there had been underlying
cause he didn't know what it was though
okay and and who figured it out well
Einstein figured out right so we so at
this point in 1905 we knew that
there was a correlation between the size
of the planet and how it moved okay and
gravity but we didn't know why and it
was a genius of Einstein to figure it
out now you you remember Einstein
because of his famous equation eal mc²
okay what what is this what does E
equals MC square mean it means that mass
and energy are correlated and this is a
revolution we we didn't we understand
this before right we just we just assume
that solids and vibrations are different
and what Einstein is saying is that in
order for a solid to exist there have to
be vibrations in the first place and
this ma this formula tells us that
within all objects There is almost an
infinite amount of energy okay because C
is a speed of light and why is this
important because this formula will
allow us to develop the nuclear bomb
right by splinting the atom you can
create almost almost an infinite amount
of energy in this world okay so that's a
major contribution of Einstein but at
his at at his time he was mainly known
for figuring out the cation problem in
space okay and what um and how Einstein
figured out is by developing a new idea
called
SpaceTime he believed that in the
heavens Spa There Was A Spacetime
curvature and so what was happening was
this a mass a huge object it would go
into the SpaceTime curvature and warp it
and because it warped it it drew things
into its
orbit and the and then these things
would have to move
around this solid okay so space-time
coverture now helps us understand uh the
laws of planetary motion first developed
by Kepler and then by and then we finded
by Newton okay and what's amazing about
about Einstein is
and and this is like this will blow your
mind okay but he did all this while
sitting at a desk at a patent office in
Switzerland he was not in a laboratory
he was not at a university he was just
thinking by himself he was daydreaming
okay so um this was just an incredible
achievement okay and so um the
mathematics it's very complicated okay
but all you need you need to understand
is that he figured out that there's a
methal relationship between the mass of
the object and the space-time curvature
okay and this
formula um tells us what the
relationship is and the and why
mathematics is important is it allows us
to make predictions and these
predictions will tell us if the if the
science actually works or not okay if
the model the theory makes sense or not
and so Einstein's theory of relativity
SpaceTime coverture it is one of the
most successful models in history
because it predicts the black hole okay
the black hole is almost um solid that
is
infinitely um massive and therefore it
attracts everything into it and sus
everything into it including light okay
so it predicts the idea of the uh black
hole and we discovered the black hole
all right so this um confirms the theory
of relativity
but um the theory of relativity also
predicts the big bag because um
SpaceTime the idea of space time is that
space is in motion right that's why you
have time because it's in motion well if
it's in motion then where did it start
there had there had to be like a
starting point and that's why scientists
not Einstein Einstein was actually
against the idea of the Big Bang but lot
of scientists believe that you needed a
big bang okay and and so we have a
working model of the big bag the problem
with this model is that there's actually
a lot of evidence against this okay so
so there are two examples the first
example is using the Hubble telescope
the most advanced telescope in the world
which which is now in outer space we've
discovered that there're actually
galaxies that came before they were due
okay so the idea of big bang is that
it's this massive energy explosion and
so the gases will develop later
but our data tells us the galaxies came
before much much earlier than we
expected okay that's that's the first
thing second problem that we have with
the Big Bang model is
that this Universal expansion it is not
constant there are times when it
actually speeds up which makes no sense
why would it speed up okay so um this
Big Bang model a lot of scientists are
now trying to reexamine it okay the
problem is is and this a huge problem is
we have we don't have a better Theory
and so to get around the problem of
these mathematical inconsistencies in
the model scientists created A New
Concept
called uh Dark
Energy Dark Energy now you think to
yourself Dark Energy means we can't see
it no that's not what it means okay and
you're like well Dark Energy means we
can't measure no that's not what it
means Dark Energy means we don't know
what it is
okay doesn't mean it exists and we can't
see it it just means we have no idea
what it is we cannot explain why the Big
Bang is expanding really fast at certain
points and really slow at other points
and so we just say it must be dark
energy okay doesn't make sense guys so
dark dark energy is not something that
you can't see it's just something we
don't have no idea what it is
okay all right so these are the theories
okay but the person who was most
responsible for the creation of the
Sonic method his name is actually
Francis Bacon and he spent his entire
life promoting the idea of Sonic
processes and methods um he's Mo most
well known for his book the new Atlantis
so uh in the new new Atlantis which is
like a novel the protagonist he ends up
in on an island where they have the most
advanced science in the world and and
what and the reason why they have the
most advanced science in the world is
because they turn science into a
bureaucracy a very specialized
bureaucracy okay so I'm not going to
read all of it all right but there are
different uh offices different
bureaucracies for different functions so
for example we have three that try new
experiments such as themselves think
good these we call Pioneers or miners
okay so you have an office a bureaucracy
specifically to do experiments which
means that you have an office
bureaucracy specifically come up with
hypotheses to ask questions okay
also um we have three that take care out
of them direct new experiments of a
higher light more penetrating into
nature than the former these we call
lamps so you have a team to actually
audit these experiments and figure out
how to improve them okay and and then um
lastly we have three that raise the
former discoveries by experiments into
great observations axioms and aism these
we call interpreters of nature so these
are theoreticians they're the ones who
will take this this experimental data
and combine it into a theory and so
bacon is proposing AIC bureaucracy and
guess what guys we have basically
achieved his vision today you look at
science today it's essentially a
bureaucracy all right now one of the
foundations of this bureaucracy was the
founding of the Royal Society of London
in 166 in 1660 okay why is this
important because For the First Time
ssts are allowed to present
their findings before a group of peers
who will question and doubt them and
this will enhance their research process
okay so the founding of the roal society
was fun fundamental as you can imagine
what will come next is Publications
magazines that um will showcase a lot of
um these new new discoveries um the
founding members of the Royal Society
include Christopher Ren who was a very
famous
architect as well as Robert Dole who's a
very famous um canas okay so that's a
basic background in into the history of
the S Revolution um today we are asking
ourselves a very deep question so the S
Revolution separated science from
religion and there's a lot of concern
that this is is this has created a lot
of ethical issues within science okay so
let's look at three major issues the
first major issue is the idea of
artificial intelligence basically we're
trying to create God and that's a huge
concern what happens when the computers
are much smarter than humans okay second
is the idea of nanotechnology where
we're trying to go into the at Atomic
level and change the laws of nature okay
we're trying to defy God and the third
is the IDE of genetics where we are
trying to change people's genetic um
blueprint print so that we can have
designer babies so that um babies will
not will be free from cancer also we're
trying to develop um immortality okay
we're looking for the exact the elixir
of immortality okay so these are three
massive ethical debates within science
and my argument to you today is that
this is the wrong question to ask okay
this is the wrong question to
ask these are not possible within the
current Sanic framework that we have
today in fact I would make the argument
that these three are essentially
Illusions Hocus Pocus magic or you you
can even go as far as to say they
are deliberate scams so artificial
intelligence is the example that we are
most calm that that we're most F
familiar with okay so I'm sure you've
all used chat gbt is it any good no it's
not will get any better no it won't okay
so but there's so much hype around it
okay um I I I don't have time to go into
artificial intelligence but if you want
to um know more about artificial
intelligence and why it's a scam I can
do so later on okay just just ask me all
right so the real problem is this okay
the real problem is this science has
become an imperial bureaucracy that's
the real
issue all right if you think think about
the world we live in today the field
that is most like the Imperial
bureaucracy of
China um is science today science is
above Nation it is above government it
does it does things by itself okay and
what's science doing science is
promoting um it its own
bureaucracy there if there's no
accountability if there's no
responsibility if scientists don't
actually have to tell us what they're
doing then it's not that they will
become God it's more like they'll become
corrupt bureaucrats does that make sense
it's more likely that they will take all
these billions of dollars the
government's for them and they'll just
waste it all okay why because they can
it's much easier for people to be lazy
greed and corrupt than is for them to
become God
okay all right so let me let let me um
explain Okay so
I I know this a hard idea but genius
does not come from hard work it does not
come from Sonic process or sonic method
it comes from intuition imagination and
inspiration okay so remember when
Einstein he was just daydreaming his
theories okay remember when Newton he
was working on theology he was working
on Alchemy and he and then he developed
the ideas of calculus okay this is this
is true consistently throughout history
this is a passage from the book The
Cosmic serpent by jery narby okay I'll
just read it to you many of Science
Central ideas seem to come from Beyond
the limits of rationalism people do
not logically deduce these
ideas Rainy Day card dreams of an Angel
who explains the basic principles of
materialist rationalism to to him this
is no different from Muhammad who was
meditating in the cave and the angel
Gabriel appeared before him it's
religious Albert Einstein Daydreams in a
tram approaching another and conceives
the theory of
relativity right James Watson scribbles
on a newspaper in a train then rides his
bicycle to reach the conviction that DNA
has the form of a double helix so what
giv rise to Great science to great
ideas it well
imagination intuition and also faith
that you are correct right that's
Galileo Galo was actually convinced that
he was right even though the science was
very sloppy okay in fact um there's very
famous story where Einstein in 1930s and
40s he was having a huge argument with
Scientists who are arguing for quantum
mechanics specifically Neils bore
okay so um if you look go go and look
back in 1930s and 40s and you look at
the arguments what you will find is that
Einstein was very clear was very logical
and was very um Sonic sound okay and you
will find that Neil's bore was unclear
illogical and very sloppy over science
but Einstein was wrong Neil Bor was
right today quantum mechanics is a
science that underlined all the
technology that we have today including
the computer okay the semiconductor the
transistor computer all right so so
that's a really important thing we have
to remember about science at first it
seems wrong but because the people who
believe in it have so much conviction
and Faith they eventually Triumph okay
all right so that's how science develops
and this this is the argument
of um Thomas in this book the
structure of Sonic revolutions okay this
is a book that I highly recommend um if
you ever stud this History of Science
this is a book the first book that you
will read because he goes into how
science develops over the centuries and
the central argument is that science
does not develop like peac meal and
slowly and methodically okay it goes
through revolutions and Paradigm
shifts all right okay so um
so I know this is going to be a bit long
but it's really important that we read
him okay paradigms gain their status
because because they are more successful
than their counter competitors in
solving a few problems that the group of
practitioners has come to recognized as
acute right so tmy for his time was
considered revolutionary because he saw
the problem of why why is it the moon
revolves around the earth okay he
provided cosmology that was simple and
which fit into
theology to be more successful is not
however to be either completely
successful with a single problem or no
success successful with any large number
okay so tomy's solution only solved a
few problems it was not the complete
solution the success of a paradigm is at
the start largely a promise of success
discoverable in selected
and still Inc complete
examples okay so a the Paradigm at first
it's actually promising but it's not at
all
convincing normal signs okay the sign
that we practice today consists in the
actualization of that promise and
actualization achieved by extending the
knowledge of those facts that the
Paradigm displays as particularly
revealing by increasing the extent of a
match between those facts and the
paradigm's predictions and by further
articulation of the Paradigm itself okay
so this is really important guys science
is not about Discovery it's about
refinement does that make sense s
science will not give us new ideas
science will take existing ideas and
fine-tune them into something that we
can believe and that we can use to drive
technological
innovation
okay all right so let's look at another
passage turn now to another more
difficult and more revealing aspect of
the parallelism between puzzles and the
problems of normal science if it is to
classify as a puzzle a problem must be
characterized by more than an assured
solution there must also be rules that
limit both the nature of acceptable
Solutions and the steps by which they
are to be obtained to solve a jigsaw
puzzle is not for example merely to make
a picture either child or a contemporary
artist could do that by scattering
selected pieces as abstract shapes upon
some neutral ground okay so this is
really important but what he's saying is
this science today solves jigsaw puzzles
they're trying to take a larger model
and find tune
pieces that make the model much more
elegant it's not trying to reimagine the
model it's not trying to over Trend the
model it's not trying to add new pieces
to the model all it's doing is
fine-tuning existing pieces it's like
you take a jigar puzzle and and there
and there's one exactly one solution to
jigar puzzle if you don't provide that
solution you're
wrong okay does that make sense that's
what science
is nevertheless such a picture would not
be a solution okay so what he's saying
is if you come up with a new picture to
the jiga puzzle you might be creative um
you might be interesting you might be
imaginative but you're wrong okay
scientists cannot accept your solution
to achieve that all the pieces must be
used their plain sides must be turned
down and they must be interlocked
without forcing until no holes remain
okay those are among the rules that
govern jigsaw puzzle solutions so if you
are a scientist working today you're
literally solving a jigsaw puzzle the
solution everyone knows the solution if
you if you provide something that goes
against the accepted solution you will
be you will not be
accepted
okay all
right so he concludes but Paradigm
debates are not really about relative
problem solving ability though for good
reasons they are usually couch in those
terms instead the issue in which
Paradigm should in the future guide
research on problems many of which
neither competitor can yet claim to
resolve completely a decision between
alternate ways of practicing science
it's called for and the circumstances
that this that decision must be based
Less on pass achievement than on future
promise the man who Embraces a new
paradigm at an early stage must often do
so in defiance of the evidence provided
by problem solving okay so this is hard
for us to understand but if you are to
to be a true innovator it's not that you
come with a new solution to a problem
it's that you must defy the basic
premises of bureaucratic
science he must that is have faith that
the new paradigm will succeed with the
many large problems that confront it
knowing only that the older Paradigm has
failed with a few a decision of that
kind can only be made on faith okay so
this is why it's almost impossible to
separate religion from science if a new
discovery is to be made that person must
believe that he is sent by God to tell
us the truth okay that's Galileo Galileo
if you actually met the person you would
think this guy's a complete all
right he's arrogant he's obnoxious all
he does is make fun of you okay but he's
driven by a Divine mission to spread the
truth and because he created this
conflict with the church it became an
National um controversy and not focused
attention of scientists and and they try
to resolve this issue okay so science
scientific innovation genius it's not a
tea party all right it's a
revolution okay so um I'm going to
summarize what we've discussed okay
because because um this was a
lot okay but but but but I want to
summarize what we did so that you have a
basic framework to understand um what
I'm I'm talking about because um
there'll be other classes on these
topics all right um we'll be discussing
Quant mechanics at a future date so I I
I want to make sure that um we
understand the argument Okay so argument
is this for most of History Science was
part of religion okay science was about
validating this um
religion but this creates a problem we
call confirmation
bias confirmation bias meaning that we
will
only look at evidence that supports our
claims and we do this every single day
okay we all want to be right we all want
to feel good we all want to be confirmed
and validated by the world around us
okay so um there's a very famous
experiment called the Dunning cougar
you've heard of this right okay Dunning
cougar the D and cougar experiment so
dun and cougar were two American
psychologists and they were teaching um
an undergraduate class or foreign
students and they made these students do
two things the first thing is they made
every student take an IQ test okay the
second thing is they asked student how
they think they did on that IQ test were
you on top 5% were you on the bottom 5%
were you average okay it turned out that
once they um looked at all the results
not one student predicted his or her
class ranking those who did really well
the top 5% it was pretty easy for them
so they assumed it was easy for everyone
okay so they underestimate the
performance by about
10% those who did the worst didn't
really
know what was asked of them okay so they
overestimate the performance in fact
those who got the it most wrong were the
worst students so maybe the top they
were the bottom 10% but they thought
they were average okay and what this
tells us is
this
doubt
self-doubt it's really the mark of
Genius okay if you're able to doubt
yourself if you're able to question
yourself if you're able to self-reflect
that's a sign of an accident student
okay in fact the bad sign of accident
student so the question then is how do
you
take
um how do you bring doubt into science
what you do is you separate science from
religion and you create a
bureaucracy around science in order to
instill doubt in the Sonic process okay
that's a solution um proposed by Francis
Bacon and again it is the most
successful solution in human history all
right
so um the starting process is
hypothesis
experiment um data
analysis um okay
replication okay does that make sense
you have a hypothesis you you then test
it out if it works according to data you
then have to replicate the experiment to
make sure that you are correct now the
beauty of this model is that you can
actually um you can actually make it
into bureaucracy right so each
department does its own thing and so
what happens is that each department
is inspecting and auditing the work of
the previous Department to make sure the
results are accurate and correct
doesn't make sense and it turns out if
you do it this way well it's
revolutionary and it explains the world
that we live in today it explains why
semic progress has been so fast and uh
so remarkable these past 300 400 years
okay but embedded in the
system are lots and lots of other issues
okay which which
um I will discuss the first is idea of
political control it takes a lot of
resources ources to run the system and
as a result you can allow politicians
come in and interfere with the science
okay that's the first problem second
problem is that over time each
department will over
specialize okay you have over
specialization which means that these
departments are now unable to
communicate with with with each other
because the underlying
assumptions um the Science Under of of
each of each department will be
different okay so if you want
experiments we use you use a lot of
instruments okay all these instruments
are so
complicated that normal scientists don't
really understand what you're doing okay
so that's second problem over
specialization the um um third problem
is um the idea of
accountability
okay how do you know if each department
is doing a good job or
not right you you can't because now
they're over
specialized the word we use is they are
now um
aloof okay so there are many problems
with this system another problem is
insularity meaning that you have to
spend like 20 years in school before you
could even be even enter the system okay
in insul creates gatekeeping which means
that only if you play by the rules only
if you V it can you enter the
system okay and as a result you no
longer have any
creativity so this is a great irony of
science um science was initiated
inspired by The Genius of Galileo Newton
and
Einstein but today science has develop
to a point where it no longers welcomes
Galileo Newton or Einstein okay why
because Galo is an he doesn't
get along with other people they will
let him in Newton is crazy right he's
Alchemist he he believes that the Bible
will reveal the end of the world he's
crazy they won't let him man Einstein is
really bad at mathematics he doesn't he
would fail all these mathematic tests in
order to get into the system he would
probably he probably would not get into
graduate school today right so this is
the world we live in so don't worry
about artificial intelligence don't
worry about uh billionaires living
forever don't worry about nanot
technology okay worry about the fact
that we've come to a point in our in our
civilization where we are now in capable
of
innovation okay all
right so that's it any
questions just a small
observation when you uh when you set up
this lecture and you talked about
premodern science and relied on
intuition and faith and Imagination I I
was really getting ready to push back
you say hey that's a lot of what makes
science like modern science great and
you brought that in you know very
nicely okay well thank you thank you um
great any
questions okay that's okay so um I I got
a light question okay great um I I
didn't know about Newton's predictions
about the end of the world but if you're
saying 2050 2060 what do you think the
chances are that he was right okay um
okay so Newton okay so um why do we know
that
Newton um pred predict to the end of the
world Okay the reason why is this so
Newton didn't have any family he didn't
have a wife he didn't have any children
um so his entire estate was left to his
nephews and his nieces and um new and
Newton also left them a lot of money
okay these are Aristocrats Newton Newton
is actually the first commoner the first
non-royal in English History to receive
a state funeral he's the first commoner
to be buried at West westmin Abby okay
so it was a very big deal um um back
then um and his relatives obviously were
Aristocrats but the thing about
Aristocrats is that over time they
become poor so and what do you do when
you become poor well you sell off what
is valuable and so Newton's papers
Newton's
papers all his
notes were auction off in like I think
the 1930s I I I I I don't remember okay
1930s and you would imagine that
everyone would want these notes right
cuz like they reveal genius to you but
for whatever reason um they didn't
really sell very well and and the in the
and the cell was so bad the oxygen was
so bad that it was sold peace meal okay
and one person who bought the notes was
um John keing the the economist John
Kings The Economist and he was so
excited to read the papers of Newton he
was like oh my god there must be so much
mathematics in these papers that would
lead to new discoveries right so when he
actually read the paper he was
absolutely a gas at what he discovered
it was Alchemy it was
Theology and so um what um Newton was
trying to do was he was trying to read
the
Bible and look for secret code I mean he
was he was crazy okay look for a secret
code within the Bible that would tell
him the future and he was actually
convinced I something call the second
coming he was convinced that Jesus will
return I me these are all Christians at
this point right he was actually
convinced that um Jesus will
return and so he wants to know when he
would return and how he would return
okay so I I so I think he made the
prediction 2060 but I can't I can't be
sure but but he made a prediction when
the world will end what's more important
for us is that he became what we know
what we call a Christian Zionist
okay the idea of Christian Zess and this
is really important is
that once you predict the future and you
know when Jesus is returning you want to
know how he returns and you became
actually convinced that for Jesus to
return certain conditions had to be met
in order to facilitate his return one
major condition was the return of the
Jews to Jerusalem because at this point
um Jerusalem was being controlled by the
Ottomans okay he was actually convinced
that we have to get all the world Jews
and return them to Jerusalem okay only
problem was Jews didn't want to go back
okay and so um I think Newton and this
is completely Unknown about him okay
he's actually one of the founders of a
mov called Christian Zionism is let's
figure out how to get all the Jews to go
back to Jerusalem and this will start a
process which will culminate with the
return of Jesus
okay so that's um um Newton um and so
what this tells us okay and this is also
something that is really important is he
was part of a secret society with John
Lock and some other really important
individuals in a secret society I mean
like they were considered they consider
themselves the true church right so um
Newton in his notes he was very clear he
thought the Holy Trinity was nonsense
there's only one God okay and he was the
representative of God on Earth he was
here on a Divine Mission so he's part of
the secret society to try to achieve
Christian Zionism and to discover when
the second coming uh will happen so he
makes this prediction 2060 so when so
whether or not Newton is correct that's
not the issue the issue is that with his
power with his influence he was heavily
promoting Christian Zionism in England
and as we know what will happen is these
people will go to
America okay a lot of these people who
are Christian Zionist they will go to
America believing that America is the
New Jerusalem and then what will happen
later on is um these zionists Christian
zionists will link up and they will plot
to um bring the Jews back to uh
Jerusalem and this and this leads to
something called the Bal for declaration
right which is to say that after World
War I when the Ottoman Empire was
defeated um the British Empire um now
gives permission to all the Jews in the
world to return to Jerusalem whether or
not they want to okay so this is why
history is so important because you
cannot possibly understand what's
happening in the Middle East today
without first understanding all this
history right so does that make sense
okay all right
great so oddar he was right 2060 things
are going to well well well again okay
so I'm just kidding I'm just K so 2060
again uh that's not the issue the issue
is that there are very powerful people
in this world who believe in this and
who want who believe that it is divine
mission to make this come true to use
the power to use her influence to use
her money to make this prediction come
true it's not really a prophecy
okay it's really a
plan this is what it is it's a plan it's
like how do we bring back Jesus because
when Jesus returns the world ends and
everyone's happy okay that's Heaven
comes on Earth but how do we make it
happen well here's the plan Christian
Zionism right so that's that's that's
that's my real concern whether or not
the world ends in 2016 I don't know okay
but the fact that there are really
powerful people of the Statue of Isaac
Newton with like almost unlimited
resources and unlimited power they
actually believe in this and they want
to make this come true that should be
the major concern
right okay so I apologize for for going
out on this tangent okay but um so uh we
don't have class on Thursday but next
Tuesday we'll start the Age of
Exploration okay